JANET RANKIN: A common
active learning technique
that people often use, or
maybe the first technique
that they use, is
personal response systems.
So that's an
opportunity for students
to respond to a question.
And that can be anything.
It's usually a multiple
choice question,
but it doesn't have to be.
And it can be anything
from a show of hands--
who thinks the answer is A,
who thinks the answer is B,
who thinks the answer is C--
to dedicated devices
and applications
that allow students to
respond to questions.
So there's pros
and cons for each
of the different
techniques, but the essence
of all the techniques
is that students
are given an opportunity
to think about the answer
that they think is correct,
and then respond to that.
And there is evidence
to show, research
that shows, that when students
make a claim, when they're
asked to make a public response,
a public claim as to what they
think the correct answer is,
that makes them more committed
to the answer.
And then they're more likely
to remember or to even notice
if their answer is incorrect.
It primes the
student for learning.
And that's the biggest
advantage for any
of these personal
response systems.
The disadvantage with having
students raise their hands
is that in a big lecture hall,
it can be hard to count, right?
It can be hard to say,
OK, how many people raised
their hand when I said A?
How many when I said B, etc.
So that can take up time and
it can be pretty inaccurate.
The other thing that
people do sometimes
is they'll use like,
just a sheet of paper.
They'll put on letters
and then the students
can fold the paper up.
And depending on how
they want to vote,
they just hold it up so that
really only you can see it.
Point of fact is other
students can kind of tell what
the other students answered.
And if I know that
a friend of mine
always gets the
answer right, then I
might just look and
see what he or she said
and then answer the same.
So it might not give us a
real accurate measurement
of what every student thinks.
The other problem
with that is this
can be hard to read
in a big lecture hall.
Sort of the first kind of
digital or electronic personal
response systems were
these dedicated clickers,
is what they're called.
And students literally,
they log into the system.
They turn their devices on.
And you ask a question,
and then the students
respond A, B, C, D
using the touch pad.
Some clickers lets
students actually
type answers, so open response.
They can actually type
a word, or a number,
or a set of numbers.
So that can give you a
little bit more flexibility.
And then the software on
the instructor's computer
will create a
histogram of responses.
So you know right away the
distribution of responses.
If you have more than
70% of the students
get the question
right, you probably
just want to state the
correct answer and move on.
You can also say, if
you didn't get it right,
here's some extra resources
or go to the TA office hours,
or whatever.
But in general, if more than 70%
of the students get it right,
you can move on.
One thing I like to do is if
I really have a resounding,
say 75%, get it right, I like
to ask a follow-up clicker
question that says,
how confident were you
in your answer?
Because sometimes
students will just guess.
And if you give them
the opportunity to say,
yeah, I got it right, but
I don't really know why--
that might be the situation
sometimes, that a lot of people
get it right, but not that many
people know what's going on.
So you want to know that too.
If between 30 and
70 get it correct,
then I like to move
into the pair share.
So I like to say, OK.
Let's divide up.
Looks like we have a pretty
good split of answers.
So let's talk to
each other and we
can do some peer-peer
learning where
peers can try to argue
their point to whoever
is sitting next to them.
And then I ask
them to vote again.
Now, when things
are working well,
people actually converge
to the correct answer.
And generally speaking--
I think it was Eric Mazur
has a preliminary
research study that
shows that when you
put two students
with the incorrect
answer together,
they actually tend to
converge to the correct answer
because they argue
each other out
of their respective
wrong answers.
So that can be pretty effective.
You do have to have a
pretty good distribution
of incorrect answers
for that to work.
If two students had the same
incorrect answer, generally,
speaking they stay embedded
with the incorrect answer.
If less than 30% of students
get the correct answer,
you probably just want
to stop and reformulate
your explanation and really
go over everything again,
because that's really
not a lot of people
that know what's going on.
So that's the general
ballpark for how to proceed
with the clicker questions.
In between the pieces of
paper and the clickers
are some newer technologies,
new applications.
One is there's a
few applications
for web-enabled
devices, like Socrative,
which is a software
that you can download.
The instructor
downloads it and then
students log into a room using
their web-enabled device.
So they log in and then no
one has to buy anything extra,
but you are assuming
that every student has
a web-enabled
device, and you are
saying you're happy
if they take them out
in your class, which may
not be true for everyone.
So that's the issue
with that, access
and also whether you want
the smart phones out.
An application that I think
is a really great compromise
is something called plickers,
with a P, P L I C K E R S.
And with that, the instructor
downloads an application
on his or her smartphone
or web-enabled device,
it has to be a
device with a camera.
And then the instructor
downloads these PDFs,
which are just pieces of paper
with these patterns on them.
They're all different, and I
believe you get 40 patterns
for free and they're reusable.
And so each one is unique and
you give them to the students.
And students then
vote A, B, C or D.
There's four sides to the shape
and four letters, A, B, C, D.
And if they think
the answer is A,
they hold it with
the A at the top.
If they think it's
B, they hold it
with the B at the
top, et cetera.
And you can use your
web-enabled device,
and you scan the crowd
with the software,
and that actually
picks up the responses
and creates a histogram.
So I think that's a
really nice compromise,
because it gives
you the histogram,
it has student
anonymity, and students
don't need anything
but the piece of paper
that you gave them.
And you can actually
reuse the piece of paper.
We printed sets on card stock,
which are pretty durable.
And we can use them
over and over again,
so the students don't
need any extra technology.
For educators that are
thinking about using
some kind of personal response
system for their students,
there's a couple different
levels of how far in to get
and how fast.
The first step would be to
construct some really good,
thoughtful questions
that students can answer
in a multiple choice way.
That would let you use the
clickers, or a show of hands,
or any of the other methods.
It is important to construct
the clicker questions in a way
that students know they're
really meaningful, that you're
not just asking kind
of silly questions.
You want to ask them
questions that are a bit rich
and that also lend themselves,
as I said to, if students,
you know if a decent number
don't get them right,
that lend themselves to
that peer-peer interaction,
that sort of debate
with each other.
So want to think carefully about
your learning outcomes, what
you want students to
know or be able to do
by the end of the class.
And you want to
construct questions
that help them
get there and test
whether they're there or not.
So you might use one, or two,
or three questions in a class.
And that might be it,
that might be all you do.
But you do want to make
sure that you construct
the questions thoughtfully.
The next-- sort of if you
want to go further in,
is to think about what it is,
really think critically about,
your learning outcome.
What do I want
students to get out
of this class, this
particular class?
And then construct a
series of clicker questions
that really help
students understand
whether they get it or not.
Help them argue their
point with others
or encourage them to argue their
opinion or point with others.
And then ultimately,
come to a realization
or come to attain the
learning outcomes really
by engagement with
the clicker questions
and by engagement in a
subsequent discussion.
So where the clicker
questions are really
the core of your
class and the learning
happens sort of threaded
among those questions.